Is Marijuana “healthier” than cocaine?
Hi everyone!
Crystal, your friendly molecular neuroscientist,
here for DNews.
Whenever we read the news, we see new information
about the positive benefits of marijuana and
more reasons why cocaine is really, really,
bad for you.
Recent studies report cocaine use leading
to everything from tissue damage in your eye,
to an impaired ability to see the unfavorable
consequences of your actions.
Why is that?
Is it just a case of one being more “organic”?
No.
No its not.
Cocaine and marijuana come from plants so
I guess they can both be considered “natural
products”.
But they activate completely different systems
in our brains.
Cocaine is so popular because it is really
great at activating our brain’s “pleasure
center”.
When our neurons are sent swimming in dopamine
it make us feel really, really good.
For the half hour or hour that the drug is
active in our system, we feel happy, alert,
euphoric, and invincible.
Which is great! except when it causes us to
act irrationally, make self destructive choices,
and the source of that high becomes dangerously
addictive.
Cocaine use is dangerous not just because
the drug is highly addictive, but because,
like methamphetamine, it is a powerful stimulant
that has an effect on our bodies as well as
our brains.
Cocaine use can lead to an inability to regulate
body temperature and at the right doses, it
interferes with cardiac function leading to
high-blood pressure, arrhythmia, and death.
Cocaine has been used in a medical context
as well.
It is used sparingly as a numbing agent in
nose and mouth surgeries, but that usage can
hardly be considered therapeutic and its potency
and addictive qualities, not to mention its
schedule II status as a controlled substance,
make it undesirable as an anaesthetic.
On the other hand, a wealth of research has
been performed revealing the positive health
benefits of marijuana.
But perhaps the most interesting characteristic
of this controversial plant are its anti-breast
cancer properties.
There’s been a lot of discussion over “compassionate
use” of marijuana due to reports that it
helps patients undergoing chemo battle pain
and nausea, and increases their appetite.
But quietly published studies are beginning
to reveal that compounds found in cannabis
may directly inhibit the growth of some breast
cancer cells which is an exciting result for
medicine.
Despite its legalization in many states, marijuana
is still listed as a highly controlled substance
by the US government , a classification that
makes research on this drug challenging to
perform in the US.
Given the current academic literature, I’d
say marijuana wins by a mile in terms of health
benefits when compared to cocaine, but please
remember the use of the term “healthy”
is relative! and not only is the composition
of the drug important, how its used, and the
environment it’s used in, is important too.
Lastly, neither I nor DNews condones the illegal
use of drugs so be smart out there and stay
healthy.
What do you think?
Could there be health benefits to cocaine?
Subscribe to DNews and let us know in the
comments below.
You can also find more on drugs and the brain
by following me on twitter @PolycrystalhD